kill your racist ancestor cut off a
piece of his flesh and eat it
he said chicken because there's gonna be
no more harry potter after this episode
yes the season finale of lovecraft
country is here and i'm already trying
to figure out a spell to make me forget
it so i can watch it all over again in
this video we'll be answering some of
the episode's biggest
wtf moments like dee's robotic arm
where that black shogoth came from what
exactly happened during the ceremony
and if atticus and ruby are still alive
i've got some cool theories about all of
these but before we begin
smash your robot arm on that like and
subscribe button so you're notified as
soon as one of my videos comes out
episode 10 is called full circle and the
first image we see of this sign here is
a fitting throwback to episode 1. both
the sign and d's ad for george's
guidebook are drawn in green a nod to
the green book nope not the movie get
out of here the annual guidebook for
african american travelers
which outlines safe places for people of
color to lodge and dine during their
travels particularly in the jim crow
south d is brought back home after the
group successfully retrieved the book of
names at the end of last episode however
as soon as they start the spell to
remove the curse
atticus and lady are transported to an
ancestral plane that was created by
atticus's ancestor
hannah the page the book of names flips
to when it magically opens shows a
symbol the
same symbol in the shape of atticus's
birthmark the night hannah first
opened the book of names she unknowingly
created this magic space initially
believing it to be hell
but later realizing it can be a place of
power hannah would go on to
kill herself but before she did she cast
two spells
one to give her ancestors this birthmark
which would hide their bloodline from
all who know magic hannah knew she'd be
hunted by the followers of adam since
she carries a child with titus
braithwight's blood
second she bound the book shut forever
so that the pain it caused would stop
atticus also gets a final one-on-one
with his deceased mother
dora their conversation is about having
the strength to sacrifice yourself for
something greater but if we ain't
walking toward an altar to sacrifice
ourselves
for something important
what is our purpose at this point in the
story atticus hasn't fully come to terms
with his fate
in fact he's continually told others
that he's not going to die
and i'm not dying so that was a [ __ ]
lie it's only through his conversation
with his mother and hannah that he'll
learn to accept that
death is part of his journey that's why
he takes the time to write a letter to
his father
and train dee with his shogoth and as
we'll find out atticus's sacrifice was
not in vain
as it will have made it so that white
people can no longer use magic
shifting the balance of power how this
will manifest in season 2 remains to be
seen
but this will be a huge game changer and
i'll get more into this sacrifice and
whether or not he's gone for good
a bit later in the video atticus and
letty along with their ancestors perform
a spell to remove the curse from d
transporting the two of them back to
reality the only problem is that dee's
arm the place she was initially infected
has withered away
in the flashbacks we see at the ending
there's a quick shot of hippolyta and
what appears to be the remnants of a
surgery having taken place around her
she was the one to give dee that robotic
arm remember that she's equipped with
tech from an alternate universe which
likely aided in her invention we also
have to remember in episode 8 what
atticus said about his time in the
future
i was only there for a second before the
woman in the hood came in shelved the
book of my hand
pushed me back to the port got the
robotic arm
dee has to be this woman atticus also
mentions in this same scene that he saw
white folks rioting which could have
something to do with the change from
white folks no longer having the ability
to use
magic and i could totally see a season 2
where the new villain is a black man or
woman
who uses magic to oppress white people
as payment for
centuries of racial injustice and that
it would be up to atticus letty in the
group to stop him or her i'm pretty
jealous of show runner misha green who
can take this show in so many unique and
interesting directions
in order to stop christina atticus
devises a plan to use her spell against
her
this requires a piece of himself
christina and titus braithwight
the only problem is titus is dead and
getting a hold of christina won't be
that easy
they're able to conjure titus from
beyond using the combined powers of
their ancestors
but not before he evaporates to warn
christina that they have the book of
names
he's brought back to the circle where
atticus rips off a piece of his flesh
and that was supposed to be the easy
part dee is mad at her mother for her
abandonment and not being there when she
needed her this is what really sparks
hippolyta to make it up to her by giving
her that robotic
arm a pissed christina now knowing that
atticus and letty have the book
offers to spare atticus's life and leave
their family alone
in exchange for the book as she believes
it will contain an
alternative way to grant her immortality
and when atticus says no
she removes letty's invulnerability and
we'll discuss why she gives it back a
bit later on
needing all the help they can get
atticus meets up with gia telling her
that what they had was real and he
thought that if he could deny what they
had he could deny
everything including her vision of his
death notice what she's wearing here
yeah she kinda looks like the pope but
the red is a nice contrast to letty's
blue in the next scene
red is also the color of jia's skin in
atticus's dream
we learned that gia's mother passed away
and also get a reminder what the mudang
said about her that she is destined to
be in the darkness
it's this line that spurs jia to
ultimately throw herself into the black
magic at the end of the episode there's
also an interesting line here about
choice we have a choice we can be
monsters
or heroes which is in direct contrast to
what dora said earlier in the episode we
tell ourselves we have a choice but we
don't
all of this ties into fate as we saw
last episode with the revelation that
atticus was the mysterious baseball bat
hero
we are in a time loop no matter the
choices they make
things will always happen the way
they've happened atticus is destined to
be a hero
no matter what and it'll be interesting
to see how the writers play with this
next season
letty pleads with ruby to help her
acquire a piece of christina for the
spell
after all she's family ruby will
initially deny this request as her
sister seems to only use her when it's
convenient for her
you only want to be my sister when you
need
something betty here we see dee crossing
out the faces of the all-white all-male
jury which acquitted the murderers of
her friend emmett till aka
bobo this gives us a little context as
to why she kills christina at the end
not only was she cursed and almost died
by racist cops but a racist jury led a
bunch of white murderers free for
killing her best friend there's a lot of
rage there and it could possibly set up
dee
as being the villain next season
especially if part of it were to take
place
20 years in the future the same time she
hands over that book to atticus in an
effort to change the time loop before
she kills christina she even says
i still haven't learned they referring
to white people
thought i'd mention this real quick but
the new arithia blue comic was drawn by
afwa richardson who got a shout out in
the show
she's a comic book artist and if you
haven't checked out her work you totally
should
letty and atticus get baptized letty
told christina two episodes ago
that she's turned to god in large part
to being resurrected way back in episode
two she now believes even if that was a
result of magic as christina said the
symbolism here is
striking as baptism is meant to wash
away the sins of the past
and for its receiver to resurrect anew
and this is just one part of my theory
that atticus will come back there are
just too many illusions of resurrection
and the fact jonathan majors is a huge
draw to the show
that lead me to believe he's coming back
i'll get more into the practical reasons
for his return when we explore the final
scene ruby gives letty what is
essentially supposed to be a part of
christina but since we know this is
actually christina in ruby's body the
potion atticus ultimately drinks is a
fake in the flashbacks at the end
christina has put
ruby into a coma similar to that of
williams after she catches her siding
with letty
in fact christina says if she hadn't
caught ruby maybe their plan would have
worked it might have worked
he had left ruby out of it a lot of
people online have been criticizing
ruby's off-screen death but i don't
think she's dead at all
she's just in a coma and since we aren't
exactly sure of the specifics of how
christina makes these potions
like do they have to be dead then
brought back then put into a coma or
does she just put them into some
vegetative state
it's kind of muddied but in a world
where there is a way to cure a curse
that turns someone into a bopsy twin
you better believe there's a way to cure
ruby i just can't believe they'd kill
her off like that
now huge points if you noticed ruby was
actually christina in the life could be
a dream singing sequence since
way back in episode 1 she talked about
how much she hated that song
and now she's loving it life could be a
dream she booms you bored
this song is also ironic since the very
first episode starts inside a literal
dream back at artem atticus and mantras
prepare for the spell by closing the
perimeter in salt and atticus eating
titus's flesh and christina's potion fun
fact when they were filming this it was
getting really cold out so instead of
shooting outside they recreated the
entire runes in an outdoor soundstage
letty finds out ruby is actually
christina and after a physical battle
they've been emotionally battling each
other all season
letty is dropped from the tower without
the protection of her invulnerability
spell
ultimately atticus is brought forth to
be sacrificed while gia montrose and
hippolyta
captured by the atomites watch on d is
left in the car
probably not the best place to leave a
kid since the woods are covered with
bloodthirsty shogos
but she'll be saved by atticus's shogoth
who has been kept in letty's basement
now the main theory here is that this
monster was the result of montrose's
failed spell on atticus at the end of
episode 8. remember how he said he was
dyslexic he probably screwed up the
words and said spawning this shoghoth
blood binding it to atticus and with
atticus knowing he's going to die
he wanted to introduce it to d as his
death would now make d
its new master as it is heavily implied
dee
is atticus's sister and next in the
bloodline as christina performs her
immortality spell
letty miraculously comes back to life
noticing that her mark of cain
or the invulnerability spell as we know
it has come back
in the flashbacks we know this was
christina's doing she brought her back
because she promised ruby not to hurt
her if she didn't bring her back it
would be definitive proof christina
never cared about ruby and she was being
used this entire time but bringing her
back confirms that her feelings were
true and that she probably feels
some betrayal from ruby when she went
behind her back to help letty
christina's spell is successful but this
black smoke emanates from atticus
similar to that black smoke that flowed
around during samuel's spell in episode
2.
jia throws herself into it which causes
her cumio spirit tentacles to grab hold
of both christina
and atticus and this is why i think
atticus will come back
i think what gia is doing here is
transferring the immortality from
christina
to atticus we know she absorbs souls and
at this point atticus is already dead
so why does she pick him up what's the
purpose of that unless it's to somehow
transfer power i mean it could possibly
be to get these flashbacks but that
really doesn't serve any purpose other
than to us the viewer we also know that
gia herself
doesn't know the true extent of her
power who knows what this kumiho did
when controlling the two bodies all of
that aside there's also the ability to
travel in time and alternate universes
something atticus even brings up this
episode i'd jonathan majors a guest that
he'll be back these puns are terrible in
that aftermath of the giant magic
explosion
gia montrose hippolyta and letty take
atticus's body as his voiceover reads
his letter to his father now that he's
gone montrose can get a second chance at
being a father and
raise young george the way he never was
it ends with a quote from alexander
dumas the author of the count of monte
cristo
montrose's favorite book letty tells
christina that not only has she been
bound from magic but
every white person in the world giving
way to dora's words that atticus will
change
everything she says magic is ours now
which could mean letty and her family
but also
all black people as a whole it's a way
to reclaim their power for centuries of
injustice discrimination and prejudice
at the hands of white people who abused
it i just want to say thank you to
everyone who has followed my breakdown
videos all this way this show was a
blast to cover and i hope you'll
consider liking sharing and subscribing
as i'm always doing new breakdowns for
the latest shows thanks for watching
come follow me on twitter and instagram
at thinkstoryyt
and until next time remember daddy loves
you very much